hi I'm Julie gerberding i'm answering
virginia's question from melbourne
question was what is my most memorable
davos moment and the answer is easy i
just loved a meeting we had yesterday
where we gathered a group of creatives
together people from a wide variety of
backgrounds to really think through how
can we encourage people to think about
their health as a sustainable resource
in the same way that we think about our
ecological environment as a sustainable
resource so can we really engage people
and appreciating that health as a
treasure that it's something that we
can't take for granted and that if we
invest in it properly it will grow and
become more and more valuable throughout
our whole life span we also talked about
health not just as a personal resource
but as a community resource and one that
we might be able to connect through
gaming or through electronic measurement
or through other ways that people can
come together and really create a whole
greater than the sum of the parts